we're now in 1944 and things are really
starting to close in on the Axis powers
now we can start in January you might
remember you've had the siege of
leningrad going on for several years now
incredibly bloody siege incredibly hard
on the civilians of leningrad
but the soviet army is finally able to
end that and so you see from these troop
movements on this map starting in
January of 1944 with the end of the
siege they're able to really take the
offensive and start marching through the
Baltics through the Baltic States at the
same time you have the Soviet armies
marching and they're able to they're
able to force the axis to surrender in
the Crimea you fast forward further into
the year further into 1944 you might
remember in 1943 the Allies were able to
land on Italy and force the surrender of
Italy to the Allied powers but that
doesn't mean that Italy as we know it
today or even as we know it then was
free of the German troops or from from
the axis troops and so the Allies are
continuing to slog through slog through
Italy and in particular Rome Rome did
not get liberated in 1943 the Allies had
to continue bombing Rome and it doesn't
get liberated until June of 1944 so Rome
is liberated so liberated in the summer
of 1944 that happens June 5th the next
day and this is probably one of the most
famous events in world war two
especially from an American point of
view something that's documented in many
films is June 6th d-day 1944 you have
the invasion of Normandy the amphibious
invasion of Normandy probably most
famously depicted in the opening scenes
of Saving Private Ryan where you have
British primarily British and American
troops they're able to storm the beaches
of Normandy successfully which allows
them which allows them to start making
progress in northern France towards
Germany now also in the summer of 1944
rockets start to get involved in a
serious way in World War two the Germans
are trying to send
they're v1 rockets over to Great Britain
and the v1 rockets this is just
significant from the history of
Technology obviously today Rockets play
a big deal if we were ever in a whole
bunch of context and this was the first
time that they were deployed in a major
way during a war the first v1 rockets
they weren't all that impressive they
traveled three or four hundred miles per
hour slower than modern jet liners they
didn't travel at that high of an
altitude but as we'll see or as we'll
see even in this video within a few
months by by by September they were
sending in v2 rockets which were far
more advanced going several thousand
miles per hour
getting to altitudes of tens of miles
high and carrying even larger payloads
so the Germans are really starting to
push the envelope in terms of rocket
science what's good about the Allies is
is that the Germans are kind of they're
developed this technology a little bit
late they're starting to be on their
heels obviously on both the Western
Front and the Eastern Front and even in
the South the Allies are really on the
offensive now but rockets are starting
to get involved be ones in the summer
and then the v2 s and then the v2 s
in the fall now also as we go into the
late summer and fall you see the
Russians after defeating the Germans at
Kursk are marching our marching towards
are marching towards Poland and marching
in particular towards Warsaw as we get
as we as we go through 1944 and at the
end of nineteen forward at the end
really at the end of at the end of the
the summer of 1944 in August of 1944 you
have the Polish uprising you have kind
of the the rebels the the underground is
taking on the German occupiers so this
is August 1944 August 1944 with the with
the Russian true or the Soviet troops
not that far away they're getting closer
and closer and closer to Warsaw
now also in August of 1944 you have
Paris is liberated so this is August
25th 1944 Paris is liberated and then as
we go later into that
year British troops are able to liberate
Athens so British troops are able to
liberate Athens so Athens is liberated
and actually this once this liberated
then you start having the beginnings of
the civil war of the the Greek civil war
that occurs between kind of the
government troops and the Communist
Tories who say the more left-leaning
people who are involved in in fighting
against the Axis powers so even though
they were liberated as kind of the start
of another unfortunate chapter with the
Greek Civil War and then finishing out
1944 the the Axis powers and
particularly the Germans they weren't
done yet even though the war is not
looking good
they finally mount a I guess you could
say one of their last counter-offensives
it's not their last major
counter-offensive and that's over here
against the Allied troops particularly
the American troops at the Battle of the
Bulge and this starts this starts in
December of 1944 it's called the Battle
of the Bulge because the shape in which
so if the Allied you know the front the
allied front looks like that as it is as
it is advancing the Germans mount a
counter-offensive and they're able to
create a what's called in military terms
a salient where they're able to push
through or they're able to push through
and kind of create and create this bulge
and this is an incredibly bloody battle
it's actually the most bloody battle
faced by American troops they lose
nearly 20,000 true that not not just
lose a twenty thousand died American
troops died just in the Battle of the
Bulge that starts in December of 1944
but this really is the the Germans last
hoorah you can see the writing on the
wall troops approaching from the West
troops approaching from the east troops
approaching from the south